[музика]
вітаємо це програма У фокусі Європа я
Лара бабалола Ласкаво просимо ракету
знову влучають у цивільні об'єкти в
Україні виводячи з ладу електро та воду
постачання руйнування енергетичної
інфраструктури призвело до відключення
електроенергії по всій країні навіть у
містах на крайньому заході України таких
як Львів мешканці залишилися у темряві
та при низьких температурах у столиці
Києві люди ховаються від обстрілів на
глибоких станціях метрополітену на
півночі України зростають побоювання
щодо відновлення російських атак Ці
українські солдати дислокуються на
кордоні з Білорусією пильно стежать за
своїм сусідом Білорусь союзник Росії
дозволяє путінським військам
використовувати свою територію як зону
розгортання коли війна почалася в лютому
російські солдати намагалися наступати
на столицю Київ і з цього білоруського
регіону українські солдати в Чернігові
знаходяться в стані підвищеної бойової
готовності сповнені рішучості не
пропустити ворога знову через північ
на крайній півночі України мобільний
зв'язок не ловить тож карти ведуть нас
до кордону з білоруссю Чернігівська
область була захоплена коли Росія
вторглася у лютому Але у квітні Україна
повернула її назад
це російська техніка яку вони залишили
відступаючи в наших лісах її дуже багато
ми патрулюємо ці позиції Цей ліс і ми
дуже пишаємося такими трофеями та
збройними силами України
сили України ця російська гармата тепер
на озброєнні українських військових
бійці тут постійно напоготові
Я думаю что я думаю що все може знову
повторитися тому що вони програють на
інших фронтах Тож вони можуть вирішити
Відкрити новий фронт
Дмитро раніше працював на залізниці за
майже 9 місяців війни він провів з
родиною лише два тижні
Він дуже злий на Росію
в мене з'являється злість тому що їх
народ підтримує загибель мирних жителів
якби ми гралися у війну і гинули б
тільки військові тоді не було б такої
образи але коли Весь народ радіє
загибелі дітей скалічених дітей яким
невідомо Як жити далі це мене злить
людина і злосна
з Чернігова також служить тут йому лише
20 років
Я вважаю що я в чудовій фізичній формі Я
швидко вчуся
У нас тут немає поділу на вікові групи
від 18 до 60 років
і ми всі рівні ми
це українське прикордонне село
побоюється нових обстрілів кажуть що
російські військові Всього за 30
кілометрів звідси але виїжджати звідси
майже ніхто не хоче хотя я поїду Я тут
народилася Я тут дітей своїх і чужих
виховувала і я поїду кудись за кого До
чого я поїду
пенсіонерка Валентина також все життя
прожила в цьому селі вона згадує страшні
моменти обстрілів на початку цього року
у березні в нас не було а в лютому були
стояли оці як дорога в нас колона стояла
ціла колона стояла ми так боялися тут що
не спали ніде ніц не спалить тут і вони
ж потім годин десь у 10 вечора вони
Потім почали стріляти такі місцями
ракетами наче
діти Валентини в обласному центрі
Чернігові але вона не планує їхати до
них
це як кажуть наша Батьківщина ми
родилися тут і живемо тут мені куди не
підемо звідси
росіяни пограбували сільську крамницю
коли вторглися у лютому розповідає Ганна
продавчиня Їй боляче бачити як сусіднє
Білорусь стала на бік російських
військових
раніше дружини із Білорусією і А тепер
що
Ані враження на їх особливо на Білорусію
раніше Вони до нас їздили в чернігову за
покупками А тепер считаю ворогами
постали чоловік і в лісі готуються до
найгіршого Олексій колишній ветеринар у
нього троє дітей троє онуків і він воює
за них
Я хочу щоб ця війна зупинилася на мені
онуки також відчули що таке війна вони
знають що таке обстріли вони втратили
друзів Мій син теж військовий я
військовий і мій зять також нам є що
втрачати Ми живемо лише раз але якщо вже
когось зачепить то нехай це буде я а не
мої діти чи Онуки
ситуація залишається напруженою Росія
здійснює авіанальоти на Україну з
Білорусі ймовірно отримує білоруські
танки
Атака може початися в будь-який момент
війна в Україні спричинила труднощі й в
інших європейських країнах Греція
бореться зі зростанням вартості
проживання і в столиці країни Афінах
один з районів згуртувався щоб допомогти
тим хто цього потребує екзархія - це
історично-соціалістичний район із
сильним громадським духом Мата живе там
ми дуже цінує це почуття солідарності
зараз вона бореться за збереження цього
духу в часи змін
з висоти пташиного польоту афінський
район екзархія виглядає як будь-який
інший густонаселений район грецької
столиці але Подивіться ближче і Ви
зрозумієте що він більш різноманітний
молодий та альтернативний
і тут більше солідарності каже Мата
кастрісюу акторка живе у цьому
ліберальному районі уже 6 років
А ви можете піти в магазин навіть якщо у
вас немає грошей на покупку у
продуктовий у кав'ярню щось поїсти і всі
знають один одного тому ми можемо тут
жити іноді навіть не маючи грошей
саме тому все більше і більше людей
переїжджають сюди у цій економічно важкі
часи в тому числі і малозабезпечені
імігранти
Ель Шеф - це місцева кухня яка роздає
їжу тим хто її потребує
наше послання тут Готуємо разом і
роздаємо їжу в знак солідарності люди
тут готують близько двохсот страв на
день
місцева влада яка мала б опікуватися
цими людьми каже бездомним і біженцям
приходити сюди
Але в цьому немає жодних проблем
тут всім дадуть їжу
ми не отримуємо жодних субсидій але ця
будівля самозахоплена з 2008 року
і протести в екзархії мають давню
історію
студентський протести проти грецької
військової фунти коли вона була
маленькою дівчинкою великі студентські
повстання тут в афінському
політехнічному інституті було жорстоко
придушене у листопаді 1973 року
ми побачили вантажівки солдатами які
їхали до університету вони співали
маршові пісні Ми зрозуміли що буде
кровопролиття і шукали укриття
Ми ніколи не забудемо ці злочини
екзархія пишається своєю історією
рух який існує тут сьогодні продовжує
традиції студентських протестів
але як для старих повстанців так і для
новоприбулих Цей район стає все дорожчим
зростає вартість оренди житла
збільшується кількість апартаментів для
туристів іноді уночі в районі спалахують
бурхливі протести
але більшість жителів які Мата віддають
перевагу мирним протестам в екзархії
наразі багато уваги прикуто до
центрального скверу району де ведеться
будівництво нової станції метрополітену
будівельний майданчик огороджений
великим парканом там цілодобово чергує
поліція
Мата погоджується що метро Це добре але
на її думку станцію Можна було б
побудувати і в іншому місці вона вважає
що влада намагається витіснити місцевих
жителів з цього району
мешканців не залучали до планування хоча
це знищить єдиний Сквер у цьому районі
це одне з небагатьох місць де ми можемо
збиратися разом де можуть гратися діти
три роки тому до цього скверу прийшов
міністр комунікації з громадськістю і
оголосив що Сквер буде повернуто назад
а ми повернемося із Сквер людям
ми припинимо беззаконня
завдяки нашій партії Ні а демократія ця
територія знову стане нормальним сквером
більшість людей в Афінах Утім не
відчувають жодних проблем щодо
альтернативного шарму екзархії
люди із усіх верств суспільства
збираються разом на щотижневому ринку у
цьому районі
що погано в тому щоб зайняти будівлю яка
роками стоїть порожньою якщо це врятує
вас із життя на вулиці ви ж ніколи не
виганяєте
група місцевих жителів зібралася у
невеликому парку щоб обговорити як можна
зробити цей район більш привабливим вони
хочуть самі зайнятися благоустрою але
поліцейські спостерігають за ними з
підозрою
[музика]
громадський простори в небезпеці в
Афінах
і навіть не знаю по всій країні
жителі екзархії хочуть зберегти її
унікальний характер Амата хоче
продовжувати заохочувати життя засноване
на солідарності та єдності навіть якщо
майбутнє району видається туманним
[музика]
Балтійське море для увкрюгера та його
Онука як другий дім
тут старше покоління передає свої знання
про рибальство молодшому але заробляти
на життя в морі вже не так просто як
раніше
це тому що забруднення і Кліматичні
зміни кардинально змінили стан води риби
мало незважаючи на спроби відродити
екосистему частина Балтійського моря
задихаються оскільки рівень кисню впав
до рекорду низького рівня
але очищення моря також потребує пильної
уваги до того що відбувається на суші
Уве Крюгер ловить рибу навколо
німецького острова узедом з 5 років
він був одним із понад 200 рибалок у
своєму рідному місті Альберт
зараз він залишився останнім але Уве
досі бере своїх онуків у море щоб
передати їм свої знання
заробляти на життя лише риболовною важко
сьогоднішніми цінами на пальне у вас не
так багато шансів якщо і продавати рибу
самому То ще якось можна прожити
цього року його онук Нільс єдиний учень
рибалка тут у засниці на Балтійському
морі
він хоче зробити рибальство своєю
кар'єрою як його батько і дід незважаючи
на непевне майбутнє І зменшення запасів
один два ящики з кожної сітки було б
непогано
Це близько 20-30 кілограмів сьогодні
вони не витягли з води навіть двох
ящиків
частина риби замала і її доведеться
викидати назад загалом цього занадто
мало щоб прожити
куди поділася риба
роками існують суворі квоти на вилуп
чому запаси не відновлюються рибалка у
викрюгер звинувачує птахів каже що вони
виїдають усю рибу але дослідники із
інституту тюнина у розтоку підозрюють що
справа у нестачі кисню
вони створили дослідницьку Зону на
балтиці хотілось з'ясувати скільки кисню
у воді і наскільки високо піднімається
температура
через кілька місяців вони отримали
необхідні дані керівник програми
Крістофер цімерман каже що результати
виявилися приголомшливими
були нижче критичної концентрації та
серпня Там просто не було кисню це може
здатися помилкою але ви бачите що
концентрація кисню стає все нижчою
нижчою спочатку середня вона на нулі і
це не змінюється
проблема масове літні цвітіння
водоростей коли водорості відмирають
вони опускаються на морське дно і
розкладаються бактеріями що споживають
кисень це створює області які більше не
можуть підтримувати життя так звані
мертві зони
різка опиняється затиснитою між високими
температурними біля поверхні і нестачею
кисню внизу до серпня простору не
залишається верхні шари води Земна то
теплі А на глибині немає кисню це
означає що тріски більше не буде
і це саме те що ми чуємо від рибалок
тріска тут більше не ловиться
цей феномен не новий але в останні роки
водоростей стало більше і мертві зони
збільшуються Чому водорості так
інтенсивно розростаються
ми разом з екологічною організацією
екологічні дні у Німеччині проводимо
дослідження біля річки Одер у
бранденбурзі тут розташовані великі
ферми з вирощування курей які виробляють
багато посліду
послід вивозиться з ферми розкидається
на поля рослини забирають його частину
але на весь тому що в Німеччині
дозволено використовувати надмірну
кількість посліду
цей надлишок потрапляє в грунтові води
та струмки які протікає через наш
ландшафт цими струмками в ній швидко
потрапляє до озеру а потім добавтики
у Польщі теж є фермерське господарство
прямо на березі озеру протягом багатьох
років інтенсивне внесення добрив
призвело до того що концентрація фосфору
та азоту у річці стала занадто високою
обидва ці елементи містяться у посліді
лише цього літа володарі стався великий
мор риби нібито спричинений надлишком
водоростей на поверхні лежить товстий
килим червоних водоростей
це спричинено людьми і люди повинні
зупинити це і покращити ситуацію
це мене бісить немає ніяких інших причин
Ось чому у векрюгер бачать все менше і
менше риби як довго це може тривати
може 5 років може 4 якщо найближчим
часом не піднімуть квоти то ніхто не
зможе продовжувати
ми просто хочемо зберегти цю культурну
спадщину
якщо стан води у балтиці не покращиться
культурна спадщина сімейні традиції і
вся рибна промисловість Балтії можуть
незабаром зникнути
хто винайшов картоплю фрі Франція Та
Бельгія стверджують що саме вони
подарували світові цю смакоту І хоча
картопля фрі не найкорисніша страва в
меню сумління не дошкуляє особливо якщо
ви замовляєте її на півночі Франції це
регіон славиться своєю хрусткою
золотистою картоплею і такими фірмовими
стравами як картопля фрі з мідіями для
ауреліме рель це можливість зробити щось
корисне для планети вона бере участь у
місцевій ініціативі яка перетворює жирне
паливо з Надією що одного дня більше
транспортних засобів будуть заправлятися
за рахунок солоного гарніри
картопля фрі улюблена їжа на півночі
Франції аурелі мірель смажать її
кілограмами незабаром її кіоску для фрід
авелі-нуїс розпочнеться час обіду
[музика]
ця партія готується за шість хвилин
нарізану картоплю Двічі обсмажують в
олії щоб вона була особливо хрусткою
аурелі використовує 100 літрів олії на
тиждень протягом двох років Вона віддає
свою стару відпрацьовану олію на
переробку для нас важлива переробка
відходів це величезна проблема
ресторанів швидкого харчування проекти
знаходиться просто тут у нашій громаді
Це добре для довкілля і створює робочі
місця тож тут лише плюси
працює у некомерційній компанії ЖЕКу
кожні 2-3 тижні він приїздить до кіоску
аурелі і забирає використану олію
роботодавець Карло переробляє її на
біодизель
з продажу картоплі фрі сьогодні
найбільші постачальники олії на півночі
а також шкільні кафетерії
Ми отримаємо ще трохи з таких місцях
лікарні але там люди їдять менше
картоплі фрі
Карло відвозить стару олію прямо до
фільтраційного цеху там вона проходить
кілька циклів У різних машинах які
відфільтровують рештки картоплі інші
домішки та воду
Мішель міларес заснував неприбуткову
компанію 15 років тому у лабораторії він
демонструє що його пальне це не просто
відфільтрована олія процес перетворює
жирні відходи на біодизель
ми викликаємо реакцію змішуючи спирт з
олією
це природна реакція але вона потребує
часу
тому ми додаємо фермент щоб прискорити
цей процес
і таким чином вся олія повністю
перетворюється на біодизель
олії для смаження виходить 9 літрів
пального і на смітті прибиральній
станції в містечку бетюнбра воно
потрапляє прямо у паливні баки Три
вантажівки уже працюють на біодизелі
незабаром на нього перейде увесь
автопарк
Усе чудово і нічим не смердить Працює
Так само як і раніше
приблизно 1 євро 30 центів за літр
заправлятися ним трохи дешевше ніж
звичайним дизельним паливом але витрати
приблизно на 10% більше рішення про
перехід на інше паливо було прийнято
більше з екологічних ніж з економічних
міркувань використовуючи олію для
смаження місто хоче скоротити викиди
парникових газів сміттєвого автопарку на
90%. це розрахунок на весь ланцюжок
виробництва палива і нам не треба його
транспортувати дуже далеко тому що воно
місцевого виробництва це все значно
зменшує викиди парникових газів що
стосується твердих частинок то вони у
нас на 60% нижче ніж у звичайного
дизельного палива
те що сміттєвозом дозволено заправлятися
стовідсотковим дизельним паливом і з
олії для смаження пов'язано зі
спеціальним винятком літа такого
транспорту замінник дизпалива не
дозволений для використання на вулицях
Франції тільки у невеликих кількостях
обідня перерва відвідувачі стоять у
черзі до кіоску аурелії фритюрниці
шкварчать не відпрацьовано олію є
хороший попит на ринку але аурелія
вирішила пожертвувати свою олію компанії
що виробляє біодизель
є компанії які купують стару олію і я
могла б отримувати з цього прибуток але
Вигода яку я отримую це екологічна та
соціальна відповідальність і це того
варте
будинку і картопля фрі набагато смачніша
коли у вас чиста совість
бажання усе мідний світ світу це те чим
багато хто з нас може зіткнутися
сьогодні для братимія - це реальність
уже майже 20 років він відмовився від
сучасного життя щоб проводити свої дні
на самоті у Стародавній печері у горах
Молдови він обходиться без
найнеобхідніших речей Хоча єфим і
відлюдник але він покладається на свою
віру щоб зберегти свій дух живим
брат єфимій поспішає додому після
щоденного богослужіння У сусідньому
монастирі А для цього треба пройти з
десяток сходинок вниз у цю скелю це
місце служило прихистком для ченців ще в
середньовічні часи
кажу що монахи живуть тут з 13 століття
Якщо вірити британський енциклопедії то
навіть з 12 століття
у нас немає архівів Тому ми маємо лише
приблизно уявлення
зараз він єдиний Хто живе тут останні 18
років без води електрики опалення Але у
нього є маленька церква раніше є фемій
працював електриком мав дружину і дітей
він не розповідає Чому покинув все щоб
жити на самоті
але ще в дитинстві за часів комунізму
він захоплювався релігією
я таємно відвідував церкву десь в 1955
по 1960 роки
це було не зовсім дозволено
у церкві була кімната загрантованим
вікном
я був десь у другому класі
я пам'ятаю як хапався за грати і не
відпускав Доки не закінчувалися служби
зараз він проводить час за читанням
текстів при свічках і довгими молитвами
коли я молюся мені приходить якийсь
спокій а іноді і біль але вони не
пов'язані між собою напряму вони
приходять одночасно і біль і спокій
часу до нього приходять селяни і просять
помолитися за їхніх померлих віддячують
бухансам хліба чи грошима
зростає кількість туристів які
цікавляться по черним монастирем
сьогодні приїхали допитливі люди з
Японії
єфимій з радістю показує шлях
Коли я прийшов сюди 18 років тому і люди
просто заходили сюди як кричав на них
зараз я спокійніше
Тепер я з ними розмовляю
світ приходить до нього а він не хоче
більше мати нічого спільного зі світом у
молодості єфимій багато подорожував
сьогодні йому цілком достатньо того що
видно з його вузького балкона перед
печерою
що він відлюдник знає про зовнішній світ
про війну в Україні наприклад
ця війна дуже складна
але вона має і духовні причини також
причина брат єфим не хоче багато
говорити про це війна болюча тема для
православного монаха чи є в нього якась
порада для людства
будьте скромними своїх бажаннях
[музика]
робіть те що повинні а не те що хочете
і тоді можливо ви зробите правильний
вчинок
і він принесе користь
Послання з усамітнення можливо не
обов'язково бути надто близько до світу
щоб давати йому правильні поради
[музика]
Просте життя в складному світі а на
сьогодні це все у нашій програмі Дякуємо
за перегляд до нових зустрічей
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2022 рік
[музика]